i want to take some time today to really
go through yesterday's trump rally in
pennsylvania not because donald trump
did anything particularly more unhinged
than normal it was filled with all of
the stuff that has unfortunately
become normal in presidential rallies in
the trump era but the reason that i want
to go through it in a little more detail
than we normally might
is because of its sociological value how
it gives
us insight and understanding
into what is happening in the world of
trumpists that exists which
i'll be perfectly honest as someone who
lives in boston and only occasionally
travels
uh to you know rural missouri or these
types of places where we have a bigger
concentration of trumpists and the
ideology
and cult of personality that's been
developed there i think it's important
for us not to
understand what's going on and to
realize that
uh only through realizing how it all
works can we actually develop a strategy
that might work to remove donald trump
it's really important for us to
understand that this is a large
contingent of the country
here in boston you know it's very
left-wing and even the right-wingers
that there are
are more romney-ish right-wingers
although there's everything of course
i don't want to gener generalize but to
some degree i have to generalize
we're talking here about tens of
millions of people
who in my sense a big portion of whom
uh could vote again for donald trump in
2020 we
we're talking about 60 million people in
2016
whose connection to reality and facts
and reason and decency has been
severed by this presidency you will
notice that the trump rally
as an institution of society has now
become reminiscent of the rallies of the
great authoritarians of the 20th and
21st early 21st century now i'm not
calling trump hitler
stop with the childish stuff what i am
saying is that these rallies over the
decades
from authoritarian strong men and
particularly ignorant authoritarian
strong men
start to take on a similar feel and
characteristic
no dissenting voices are allowed the
audience must be completely united
fervently behind whatever the strong man
says with no
assessment of the truth of what the
strong man says
the atmosphere has to be both sort of
jovial
but constantly on the verge of becoming
violent as well if the wrong thing is
said or if the wrong person appears
reverential towards the dear leader no
matter what they say
absolute and total lies stated as truth
and cheered by the audience as if they
are truth
an unsafe place for any kind
of difference of opinion a place where
everyone is constantly judging
evaluating and monitoring
the level of commitment of those around
them to
the strong man that is ranting on the
stage anyway
this one in pennsylvania yesterday was
really out of control let's look at a
few moments
this was one of trump's ugliest and most
sickening performances in a very long
time the more the walls close in
the more erratic and authoritarian he
becomes here is trump repeating the lie
that we weren't respected under obama
but now we are
i say and i've already said it twice
tonight
this country is so respected and we were
not respected
four years ago we were laughed at
of course the truth is the opposite the
u.n
literally laughing at trump during his
latest u.n speech the world
leaders last week at the nato summit
literally laughing at donald trump we
are now a laughingstock
we weren't then but facts don't matter
trump later claiming that his bogus
trade war
is helping people when it has done a lot
of damage including in the state of
pennsylvania which we will discuss
i've taken the toughest ever action
against
china's trade abuses they want to make a
deal so badly
and we're doing well with the deal but
they want to make a deal please make a
deal
we don't want to pay tariffs anymore
please please
thanks to our steel tariffs steel mills
in pennsylvania
are roaring back to life and u.s steel
has just announced a one billion dollar
investment
in mon valley works in pittsburgh you
know that right
everything is the opposite no one in the
crowd has any clue
what donald trump is talking about and
then trump tells the crowd
that they have had their best year ever
he tells the pennsylvania crowd
that pennsylvania has had its best year
ever you're in pennsylvania you had the
single
best year that you've ever had
in the history of our country not bad
now this is not only wrong it's
meaningless in a sense like what does it
mean that a state had its best year
ever but the reality is that
pennsylvania lost
about a hundred about ten thousand
factory jobs
trump's own trade policy has been
crushing their steel industry
crushing their manufacturing industries
which are important industries
in pennsylvania particularly outside of
philadelphia outside some of the biggest
cities
at one point during the rally a female
protester with a pink sign
said uh had a pink sign that said
grabbing power back
this is a reference of course to trump
talking about grabbing women by the
the sign saying we're going to grab
power back the crowd notice her
started booing trump said get her out
they threw her out
very quickly the crowd will turn on you
at these rallies
yesterday the justice department's
inspector general released a report
detailing the outrageous
scandalous and unprecedented abuses of
power
[Applause]
get her out get around trump of course
attacking
impeachment calling everything
disgusting and a fraud
now that the russia witch hunt is dead
a big fat disgusting fraud
the congressional democrats are pushing
the impeachment witch hunt having to do
with
ukraine
[Music]
but that's already failing you saw their
so-called articles of impeachment today
people are saying they're not even a
crime
what happened all of these horrible
things remember
bribery and this and that
where are they they said these two
things are not even a crime
trump then combining their two most
common defenses
in one go which is this didn't happen
and this isn't a crime it did happen but
it's not a crime
the crowd doesn't realize it or they
don't care donald trump very often will
do this he will say oh this thing that
they're saying i did i definitely didn't
do it
and by the way legal experts will often
quote people like mark levin and greg
jarrett from fox news
legal experts say there's no crime
there's no crime wait so hold on
did you not do it or did you do it but
there's no crime
it doesn't matter trump then galvanizing
anger against the media in general
another
common authoritarian technique of
uniting the crowd angrily
against any uh attempted check
on the lies and the wrongdoing of the
strong man
and trump going after the dishonest
corrupt media to say this look and i
always have to
say this you have some really great
journalists
and you have some honest publications
but not too many of them i have to be
honest with you
the legislator well you know that does
anybody think the media is honest
does anybody think they're totally
corrupt and dishonored
[Applause]
all right and then donald trump calling
the fbi scum that's a nice one right
referring to top level cops and dirty
players who are leaving
referring to intelligence officials uh
people at the fbi
so on and so forth and if you look at
what's happened
with the scum that's leaving the very
top of government
people that others used to say oh that's
one that
dirty these were dirty cops these were
dirty players
you take a look at what's going on
there's 21 of them already
and i'm not even doing they're just
leaving because they got caught
like nobody ever got caught
now at one point it actually goes beyond
parody
trump has ignored the constitutional
oversight mechanisms that the house has
ignoring subpoenas to people that work
for him directing people not to testify
of violating the emoluments clause
endlessly and he closes the rally with
we support protect and defend the
constitution
which is sometimes a meaningless bit of
drivel that we hear from elected
officials but with trump it happens to
also be
extremely opposed to the truth
indistinguishable from parody take a
look
and above all we will never stop
fighting for the sacred values that bind
us together
as one america one great country
one america we support protect and
defend the constitution of the united
states
we stand with the incredible heroes
of law enforcement
we also have some video from interviews
with trumpists outside of the rally and
some of you may be eating as you listen
to the show or watch watch the show so i
don't want to spoil your appetite with
too much of this stuff
but it won't come as a surprise that the
trumpists that are interviewed
they repeat the exact same talking
points off in verbatim that have been
fed to them by the dear leader
they have no idea what's going on and i
actually fear
feel more sad than angry about this it's
sad because
if we talk critical thinking if we
taught philosophy if we taught civics
starting
you know in middle school a lot of this
stuff a lot of these people would never
fall for this stuff to begin with but
listen to how this guy repeats
trump's phrases word for word in
defending donald trump
you start on it what gets me fired up is
the impeachment hoax
okay other issues jobs uh
unemployment the lowest black
unemployment lowest women's all those
those things are all positives but when
you have such a hoax
when we all saw the washington compost
19 minutes into his election into 2016
when he was elected they said the
impeachment process has started now
19 minutes in are you kidding me and
then all this here
and now they said they have the two
things they're going to
obstruction of congress not even
obstruction of justice but obstruction
of congress
and abuse of power which that's a big
joke because they talk about quid pro
quo
i see the video of joe biden saying
if you don't uh fire that prosecutor i'm
leaving in six hours you're not getting
the billion dollars that's on video
and they're saying oh he didn't do
anything and yet the president
asked the question no i'm not a i'm not
an english major
but the president if you read the
transcript please read the transcript
he asked a question if you would do me a
favor do me a favor if
so he's giving the ball to the ukrainian
president
it's a combination of weaponized
ignorance
red herrings misunderstandings of the
facts
refers to the transcript which of course
we don't have because they didn't
release a transcript they released a
little excerpt
it's all word for word what trump gives
them they repeat in
unwavering defense of the dear leader so
what's the takeaway
the takeaways are we still have a
country that is a western democracy
on paper and in principle but for half
of the country or almost half of the
country 40
of the country the dynamics the feel the
style
it's becoming what we see in
authoritarian strongman
nations and it should scare the hell out
of us if it hasn't already
number two we can't win by talking sense
into those people we can't talk them
into voting for someone other than trump
now i understand this is a rally these
are the rabid supporters who don't care
about the facts
now sure the rally crowds are crazier
and wackier than the people who just go
to work
and then they consider themselves
republicans and election day comes
around and they might vote for donald
trump
but in either case we've got to focus on
get out the vote we have to galvanize
our side
because a lot of these people are not
reachable and it is a waste of
time to try to convince them at the
individual level i don't think we should
do it i think we should work on get out
the vote
voter registration preventing voter
suppression and foreign meddling
in the election let me know what you
think very depressing
leave a reply if you're watching on
youtube send me a tweet
at dpakman follow me by the way on
twitter at dpakman as well